بعيون على الحدود يستقبل الرئيس الاوكراني
مسؤولين اوروبيين في العاصمه على راس
القادمين الى هنا رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه ومسؤول سياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي يركز الرئيس الاوكراني
في حديثه مع الاوروبيين على التخوفات من
حشود عسكريه روسيه على الحدود الشرقيه
الشماليه وفي المناطق الجنوبيه وفق مجلس
الامن القومي الاوكراني فان القوات
الروسيه تستعد لشن هجوم واسع خلال
الاسابيع القليله القادمه سيعيد الروس
مشهد بدايه الحرب ويبداون هجوما من الشرق
والشمالي والجنوب حينها وصلت القوات
الروسيه الى مشارف العاصمه بدات زحفا
يستهدف كييف من الجهه الشماليه الشرقيه
وسيطرت على مساحات واسعه في الجنوب والشرق
اليوم يقول وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان
القوات الروسيه استدعت قرابه نصف مليون
جندي من الاحتياط وليس 300 الف كما اعلن
سابقا بشكل رسمي
ان القلق الاوكراني له ما يدعمه في الشمال
تقول وزاره الدفاع البيلاروسيه انها باتت
تملك صواريخ اسكندر القادره على تنفيذ اي
مهمه عسكريه هذا بالاضافه الى منظومات
صاروخيه تضرب الى مدى يصل الى 300 كيلومتر
مئات الكيلومترات هذه تعني تغطيه نصف
الاراضي الاوكرانيه تقريبا بصواريخ من
بيلاروسيا هذه التصريحات تاتي بعد اختتام
مناورات روسيه بلا روسيه انتهت قبل ايام
قليله قرب الحدود بين بيلاروسيا واوكرانيا
وفق المخابرات الاوكرانيه فقد شهد البحر
الاسود كذلك تغييرات في نشاط القوات
الروسيه يزيد النشاط الروسي وتتحرك حاملات
الصواريخ على بعد 500 كيلومتر عن العاصمه
كييف وبالتالي تغطيه كل المناطق
الاوكرانيه تقريبا بالصواريخ الروسيه
هذه التخوفات والحشود تعكس الوضع
الميدانيه المتعثره للطرفين
لا يستطيع اي من الجيشين حسب تقدمه على
الجبهه الجنوبيه الشرقيه وتحديدا
ويعجزون عن التقدم اكثر للسيطره على ما
تبقى من اقليم دونيتسك ويتوقف الاوكرانيون
كذلك ويعجزون عن استعاده السيطره على مزيد
من المساحات في الاقليم او التقدم اكثر
نحو هكذا يترقب الطرفان خطط كل منهما
وتحضيراته الى الاسابيع القادمه تنتظرك هي
الهجوم الروسيا واسعا وتنتظر موسكو ما قد
يقدمه الغرب من دعم لكيف يقلب المعادله